aujourd'hui on connaît l'homme de
l'année 1982 il est à côté de moi je
vous le présente
l'ordinateur individuel ou pour
l'appeler par son nom américain mister
computer un beau plateau de lancement ça
1982 cette année symbolique marque
l'entrée dans nos chaumières de
l'ordinateur individuel ou ordinateur
personnel ou pc tout simplement avant
l'informatique était coûteuse et
inaccessible ce début des années 80 est
marqué par la démocratisation des prix
j'aime bien cette phrase parce que toi
moi le peuple nous allons pouvoir enfin
nous offrir un ordinateur un petit peu
fort là quand même là non bon on est
encore loin des machines d'aujourd'hui
il ya encore beaucoup d'enfants qui
jouent au pendu avec un crayon et une
feuille de papier mais il y a déjà des
enfants qui jouent au pendu avec un
ordinateur individuel
ouais je sais même à cette époque ça
devait y perd en mieux comme jeu on a un
peu l'impression que la jeunesse du
début des années 80 vivait au ralenti
autant vous dire qu'à cette époque tout
le monde parlait de l'ordinateur tout le
monde voulait en avoir un et on nous
annonçait déjà qu'il allait
révolutionner le monde
on savait pas vraiment ce que cette
machine allait nous apporter mais ça a
l'air super ah ouais on avait quand même
de gros espoirs et pour nous éclairer
heureusement il y avait des gens
passionnés là je vous ai trouvé le tout
premier geek 1.0
maintenant que cet appareil est terminée
qu'il est construit je vais finir je
vais maintenant l'exploiter par la
première exploitation va être justement
une exploitation radioamateurs la
réception des signaux radio télé type la
réception des signaux un télégraphie sur
l'écran de la télévision et les missions
en radio télé type est un télégraphie
directement à partir du clavier
ceci pour éviter en ce qui concerne nos
radios télés type la machine bruyante
que l'on connaît le télé type classique
que tout le monde connaît qui est très
bruyant et en morse pas ma foi c'est
quand même un petit peu plus un peu
moins fatigantes et plus amusant de le
faire au clavier à l'écran
si vous comprenez cette conversation ne
prenait pas la route
en 1982 la vitesse d'un processeur d'un
ordinateur individuel c'est à peu près 1
méga on est très loin des gigas et des
multiprocesseurs rien que ton petit
smartphone contient plusieurs
processeurs de quelques gigas en gros tu
avais un coeur un processeur de 1 méga
ya les chaos et les méga octet ya l'ilga
alors le truc comme la clé usb bat
oublie même pas en rêve
il n'y a pas encore de souris le lecteur
de disquettes t'oublie windows connaît
pas le disque dur tu oublies pour
stocker les données battues utiliser un
lecteur de cassettes
le rockeur se trouve sur une bande d'une
mini casse est tout à fait normale et je
vais demander aux systèmes de charge et
cette morne
j'appuie sur la touche lecture
et pour charger un logiciel ça pouvait
prendre jusqu'à dix minutes tout ça
juste pour un jeu de cartes my way sans
électronique des années 80 est made in
france quand même hein et bossa le
programme est en train de battre les
cartes
je vais parier une somme qui sera par
exemple de mieux
mille du dollar voilà les sommes que je
vais gagner
si j'ai quelque chose d'intéressant
le système m'a sorti automatiquement des
cartes il a vu lui même qui avait une
paire en conséquence il me signale que
je suis déjà en train de gagner une
paire
c'est à dire je suis en train de gagner
1000 dollars je peux demander les cartes
je vais demander par exemple
remplacement de la carte numéro 4 donc
je tape 4
je vais changer aussi le valais qui a la
carte 5 ans d'accord pour les changes et
jeudi à l'isie à ce moment là le système
change ses cartes
les remplace par d'autres tirées au
hasard bien entendu il constate que je
n'ai qu'une paire donc j'ai gagné 1000
dollars voilà donc un exemple d'un jeu
ici le jeu de poker qui était programmé
sur un petit ordinateur vous voyez que
la qualité de l'image est tout à fait
excellentes et que le jeu est très
simple à apprendre
nous sommes typiquement dans ce que l'on
appelle l'informatique individuelle
hausse qualité d'image 1982 c'est aussi
l'année qui voit apparaître le to7 de
chez thomson une entreprise française
lui c'est le to7 70 c'est celui d'après
en fait il n'avait pas le même clavier
processeur motorola 68 09 à un méga
hertz ram 8 ko extensible à 32 k o
quand tu vois qu'aujourd'hui c'est
minimum 4 gigas de mémoire pour que ton
ordinateur fonctionne pas peu près bien
on l'appelait théo pour téléviseurs
ordinateurs 7 je sais pas 70 je sais pas
non plus ont branché directement
l'ordinateur sur sa télé avec une prise
péritel était de la grosse bombe
c'est un ordinateur pour le grand public
pour la famille pour vous pour moi alors
que peut-on faire avec peut faire
beaucoup de choses
on peut d'abord introduit l'ordinateur à
la maison pour se mettre dans le coup de
l'informatique et pour cela dans
l'ordinateur on peut immédiatement
introduire des langages comme le langage
basic ou langages logo on peut aussi
apprendre d'autres choses par exemple
les langues étrangères
il ya des programmes d'anglais des
programmes d'allemands qui se met très
simplement
dans l'ordinateur on peut aussi jouer
avec l'ordinateur des jeux
d'intelligence ou des jeux d'astuces il
ya toute une série jeux qui sont
prévenus pour l'ordinateur
thomson était une marque très innovante
pour l'époque avec l'ordinateur il y
avait un stylo optique qui permettait
entre autres de faire des dessins
directement sur l'écran de votre
ordinateur
j'ai jamais compris comment ça
fonctionnait en ce début des années 80
on voit apparaître de nombreuses marques
amstrad atari st clair texas instruments
amiga commodore le problème c'est que
c'est un peu le bazar
rien n'est vrai nom standard et en plus
il faut connaître la programmation il
faut connaître le basic ou le pascal
c'est pas trés plug and play
malheureusement durant une décennie ce
marché ultra concurrentiel et aux
innovations constantes aura vu
apparaître et disparaître de nombreuses
marques et même tonne seul ya laissé des
plumes
la question n'est même plus de savoir si
un jour ou l'autre chacun d'entre nous
va l'acheter cet ordinateur individuel
c'est certain le grand problème est qu
allons-nous enfer là je crois qu'il faut
faire confiance notamment aux enfants
élevés avec dans un coin de la maison
cette machine devenue familière après
tout ce n'est pas parce que les gens
voulaient lire que butin berra a inventé
l'imprimerie mais c'est parce que bute
imbert a inventé l'imprimerie que les
livres sont apparus que les gens se sont
mis à lire et que la civilisation est
entré dans une ère nouvelle